[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy thursday america such great news
to report plus julie banderas is
hungover
what a surprise huh am i right she
poured herself into this chair she looks
terrible
but that's okay we'll give you a little
break right now because we're going to
have seven jokes
reg seven jokes
so both american and southwest airlines
say they'll comply with president
biden's order to force their employees
to be vaccinated
meanwhile spirit airlines will begin
requiring their employees to brush their
teeth
is that too mean
i don't know that's one president of the
toy association said this week that kids
might not get what they want this
christmas due to the national shortages
great more money to spend on strippers
said dana perrino
unbelievable pervert that she is
john gruden you know him the raiders
coach will be removed from the
buccaneers ring of honor over emails
that contained racist insults which some
say is hypocritical because o.j simpson
remains in the nfl hall of fame but
that's an apples to oranges comparison
since there's no proof simpson sent mean
emails
right he was acquitted he was acquitted
the global supply chain crunch has made
it hard to find halloween costumes in
stores so this year chris cuomo is going
to pretend to be a journalist
where are we number four is that number
four this week william shatner became
the oldest man to travel in space
scientists suspect the 90 year old took
control of the rocket at some point
because it never turned off its turn
signal
that's five
footwear brand minnetonka has apologized
for making moccasins they've made them
for 75 years because it's not a native
american-owned business to remedy this
problem the ceo says the company will be
changing its name to elizabeth warren
number six
and finally
with biden's war on energy independence
the price of coal has skyrocketed so
this christmas all the naughty kids will
be getting their stockings filled with
solar panels
and that's your seven jokes
delicious water julie you might want to
have some oh thank you so did you know
that the new york mayor bill de blasio
otherwise known as a walking tree of
turds
is removing the statue of thomas
jefferson from city hall in case he went
to public schools jefferson was a
founding father
our third president but also a slave
owner the statue has been there for
nearly 200 years a year for every
screw-up de blasio makes in a week
but after all the problems going on in
the city it was clear that this putrid
piece of marble had to go i mean think
about it a woman was beaten brutally on
the city street stomped repeatedly and
left for dead
people are dodging bullets in times
square like neo in the matrix
but damn that thomas jefferson you know
he's behind all that of course there was
the filipino nurse murdered saturday
afternoon in times square by a deranged
criminal that alleged killer had been
released after groping another female
but clearly if there was no jefferson
statue this never would have happened
there's a huge spike in homicides in
major cities it's getting so bad in
places like chicago they are installing
bleeding control kits in hundreds of
city buildings each kit contains
supplies like tourniquets gauze shears
gloves and an instruction manual i knew
the labor shortage was severe but now
you have to fix your own gunshot wounds
[Laughter]
but what do you expect when you allow
such statues to exist
now the removal of the statue was
suggested by de blasio's wife sherlane
mcrae she said i already share a bed
with a blockhead i don't need another
one staring at me while i work
but she also heads up the 800 million
dollar taxpayer-funded program called
thrive which was designed to treat the
mentally ill like the guy who murdered
the nurse but where's the proof that the
program actually did anything the money
disappeared faster than brian stelter at
a doughnut factory if you take a casual
drive around the city and you don't get
carjacked first you'll see countless
destitute zombies but it's hard to
investigate the person in charge of
helping them when it's the mayor's wife
so what do you do when you're supposed
to treat the sick and deranged and you
haven't done squat and the people you're
supposed to be helping are doing squat
everywhere
on the sidewalks in front of businesses
in the parks with dogs
and that's julie
so
you go after the statues and why
how does removing the statues make the
poor or the elderly currently being
picked off in new york any safer it
doesn't if anything when you're getting
shot at statues give you a place to hide
behind
in fact we could use a lot more statues
of really fat people
grover cleveland
henry viii hell i'll take a michael
moore
i'll take anything because increasingly
oh it's a cheap shot
increasingly the public has fewer places
to hide but the real reason for removing
statues is deflection the activist class
is a shallow stupid breed with absurd
priorities and their leaders know that
all you need to do is dangle some
performative act of symbolic justice in
front of them and like a hooker in front
of hunter they'll climb all over it
and then you don't need to do any real
work at all to fund the police bailout
thugs and rapists and watch as your city
time travels back to the 1970s and then
blame the statues and a mayor and his
wife can coast along by shifting the
conversation to erasing the past and
call that progress it's not just new
york whether it's san francisco where
they're closing down drug stores due to
crime or downtown portland and during
another night of mob violence all you
need to do are a few things demand
changing the problematic name of a grade
school cancel a holiday for a
problematic explorer remove a statue of
a problematic founder all in the name of
equity and anti-racism as the elderly
and working classes continue to get
victimized by thugs and maniacs it's a
good grift as long as you go woke you're
immune from criticism for the horrible
messes that you leave behind i wonder
what the angry black male
[Music]
thinks joe mackey how many times have i
told you not to wear my clothes i
thought you were real funny playing a
little baby wearing my jacket tired you
guys wearing my clothes you don't wear
my clothes time to pay joe mackey
hey who are you hey dyrus i'm tom
jefferson nice to meet you where's joe
oh uh joe's not here today i don't know
it's my first day i don't know where joe
is
you'll do jefferson
someone help me i i don't understand
we all understand
so remove a statue change a holiday's
name congrats you've tackled the big
problems and when a parent loses a child
or a child loses a parent to a maniac on
a city street you can tell them hey you
know i'm sorry for your loss but
remember that bust at jefferson it's
gone as well so let's call it even
let's win
tonight's guest
he's here to ruin your plans for the
apocalypse author of the great new book
san francisco an apocalypse never
michael schellenberger
she believes a chain is no stronger than
its weakest drink fox news anchor julie
banderas
she gets wasted more than your tax
dollars
fox news contributor cat tim
and walking a mile in his shoes would
only take one step my massive sidekick
and the nwa's world champion television
champion pirates
going to come to you first because you
know thomas jefferson owns slaves yeah
you know i figured i should come to you
first
yeah yeah last time i saw thomas
jefferson at the supermarket it was
awkward yes
so what do you what is you know you see
in new york it's going it's hell in a
handbasket and that's an insult to hell
no you know what
it always
it seems to me that the new excuse for
not doing anything
is to once again bring up slavery
so we had to get rid of thomas jefferson
because he did what at the time was
fashionable or was what happened there
was i hate to even say this but it's
true there was even black slave owners
because that's what
society was the good news was that or is
that we didn't do that and it didn't
take us we moved past it in record time
if you look at the other world other
places in this on this world how long
they dealt with slavery centuries
for eons we we got it we got our stuff
together relatively quick so i think
it's always hilarious that why are you
getting rid of thomas jefferson well he
owns slaves well okay so george
washington got to go pretty much
everyone from that error has to go but
that is better to say you did that
than help one sick mental person right
get help in the street but hey thomas
jefferson's gone and here's the deal the
statue that you took away in most cases
keeps somebody from getting rained on
that you're not helping yeah exactly by
the way
to your point
the whole democratic party has to go
because the democratic party the name
itself is associated with slavery they
got to change their name to something
else julie like severely hungover party
which is what you are
you don't smell like tequila though no i
don't i'd shoot a lot of gum in the
makeup chair
that poor makeup artist has passed out
[Laughter]
yeah but uh
i can't believe you on what's today
wednesday thursday so that was a
wednesday night for you every night is a
friday night
so
what do you make of this strategy to
always like like as you see these the
crime go up in the city this is almost
serious questions so you only have like
20 you lost me
sorry as crime gets worse wokism seeks
to replace the argument so you don't
notice how everything's getting so bad
does that make sense
did i lose you again i'm sorry did you
ask a question
um so first of all i think it was a huge
mistake to put your wife in charge of
anything right that's just something i
think every husband should know
ask tyrus he'll tell you
what the hell i'm just saying oh wait
she doesn't watch go ahead go ahead he
lives in barbie dream house like
literally that's where and in yeah i'm
just saying you're greg basically the
moral is just keep deflecting yes yes
very democratic of you thank you well i
mean i'm talking about mayor but it is
true but it is true and i have to say
this first of all he needs to
concentrate more on the war on crime
instead of the war on history and i
believe that thomas jefferson statue
obviously represents a stain in american
history but it's also a reminder of
where we've come man this is deep for
hungover man my head is spinning
but we have come a long way we have a
long way to go and to remove that is
absolutely ridiculous she should
actually remove her husband like banish
him right i mean if you're going to give
her control
you know make her make the best out of
it yeah welcome to the show michael this
is your first time i hope this hasn't
disgusted you yet
um i i look at the amount of time that
is devoted to statues and other symbols
and i realize that is taken away it it
it's it's not like it's a it's a pie of
time that leaders have so the more time
you spend doing this stuff you can't
help citizens it's a terrible it's a
terrible thing to do that's what
happened in san francisco i described
how the school board spent much of last
year trying to rename the schools rather
than trying to figure out how to get the
kids back in the classroom and so we've
seen yeah african american math
proficiency in san francisco high
schools is 12 percent and so they spend
their time basically trying to make
everybody feel guilty it's all
deflection all distraction it's a it's a
bad situation so sad to see it arrive in
new york too yeah it's well it's in
every major city that is run by a
democrat cat
i blame you
no don't that is wrong no because no and
i will tell you why greg okay
okay it's bad on the streets of new york
it's very very bad and you know people
you walk down the street and you see it
people yell at you and i am saying it's
bad and that says something because
first of all i normally enjoy attention
of any kind yes
and second of all i have dated at least
one homeless man yes that's true right
possibly possibly two the other one we
weren't sure about no proof of the
apartment right so what i'm saying is i
have done more right or the homeless
than all of thrive nyc
give her the 800. don't believe me
believe me i have done more
and i will make sure my husband does not
watch the show
does living in a car count as no and i
did it for free too
[Laughter]
that's a great question greg is living
in a car mean you're homeless or an
explorer they also didn't have cars hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else